were you all expecting that much drama
and and what really started it all
because it didn't take long
honestly with Olivia I really liked her
in the beginning you know first night I
thought we were gonna be best friends
and is she smirking um and and then in
Vegas she just flipped the switch for me
when I stole him first and she stole him
after literally two minutes and for me
that was you her thing you know what Jen
screw you I don't care about you it's
all about me and you can't expect me to
have respect for someone after that no
one else here would have done that the
remarks that were made about my date it
shocked me because to my face it was
always Jubilee you're so fun Jubilee I
love your sense of humor which you are
such good energy and then I watch it
back and it's like oh she's not going to
come back oh my gosh I bet Ben's just
dying in that little box up in the sky
you know let's be honest a lot of girls
didn't did not wanted you to come back
well I'm like everyone is being quiet
right now but that's how it was yeah
there was a lot of I personally hurt a
lot of girls they were surprised